man music serves multiple purposes so i  don't know none of it but 2020 was a  time where they were like okay who's  actually able to speak to  what's going on and if not speak to  what's going on say something that  that at least um  has some semblance of  truth and honesty and real storytelling  yes if you think of the nominees it was  alfredo  black habits royce  shout out to royce for finally getting  one  uh king king's disease i'm missing one  chica oh yeah jay electronics i know  chica was best known yeah electronica it  was like yo these are all like this is  all bars lyricism straight up yeah and  it was just like yo whoever wins is like  a win for the culture  i knew it was going to be nice  i told you i was like get better  and i'm nominated but i'm like all right  if i take it home i knew i was going to  feel some kind of way like oh [ __ ]